hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for yet another midnight mass
interview i've got annabeth gish here
who i'm very excited to talk about but
everyone should be warned this this is
like a full spoiler conversation if you
have not watched the entirety of
midnight mass please push pause go binge
it on netflix and then come back to this
conversation that's your one and only
spoiler warning yeah i am so excited we
get to talk again me too me too
there is
there is a lot to cover here
and i warned you i have like some
obnoxiously specific questions right now
but i'm going to start with maybe
something something a little broader
here so
on crockett island it seems like it
might be a difficult place for
someone of science to live so
before the events of the series how do
you imagine that sarah just you know
kept herself busy and even sane during
the quieter days where work wasn't as
busy for her
that's a great question you know i think
uh dr sarah gunning who also identifies
as gay um she has kind of always been an
outsider on the island even when she was
growing up
uh she makes reference to it also when
she says that that priest the father was
always looking at me like he knew you
know so she's always felt an outsider i
think she went left and went away to
college medical school asap
and didn't spend much time on the island
she was on that ferry a lot
i presume and then when her mom
started getting her dementia
she came back to take care of her
because you know her mom
is her is her love line
so i was wondering about that with
medical school and also because there's
such a heavy emphasis on erin and
riley's time off island do you think she
went to medical school with no intention
of coming back to be the crockett doctor
yes correct i i don't think she had the
intention of coming back to be the
dr gunning on crockett island no but i
think that that because she is a helpful
person you know she wanted to
it was a time to help her mom and also
be there for others
all right let's finally talk about
working with alex esso now which i'm so
excited i was trying to steer clear of
it during the main junket but i don't
have to anymore
then you tell me a little bit about
honing that dynamic making it a
believable mother-daughter dynamic even
though alex is so so young and playing a
role that is far older than she is
yes yes well you know to to alex's
credits
you know to mike's credit to the special
effect makeup credit you know she spent
a lot of time with prosthetics
and that is not an easy thing to do
uh but also to get your voice right and
your body mannerisms and the walking and
and i think she does a great job because
it's almost i think i mean you can
answer this more but i think it's quite
a surprise her how she
she changes you know and and blooms back
into youth
um
for me
you know i've
known alex and uh it was just
such an easy pleasure to work with her
she's smart she gets that she and i have
the same sensibility like not nothing
we're more subtle than big
and just want to be truthful so it was
it was a pleasure and wild to watch her
get younger
great success in that department so
you've got that element of the
relationship and i was also wondering a
little bit about george what was sarah's
relationship like with her father figure
was it a traditional father-daughter
type connection that they had when she
was growing up i think the backstory was
that yes he was a he was a loving
kind
man um
probably not the the dynamic father that
she
would have hoped for progressive right
the island itself is is
you know very evangelical
um faith-based but but i think she grew
up happy right i think she she had a
happy solid her mother loved her and and
then
she was able to
to get the heck out of dodge
his busy examining every single piece of
set dressing in her house and some of
those photos that are on the wall say
exactly what you just described yes
indeed indeed and again i have to say
the production design on on
always on mike stuff but this one in
particular midnight mass
it's so detailed and it is so rich and
i think is a character in itself because
everything's so worn in and
weathered and oh my gosh you would just
we would walk on our sets and
in fact
in our house set
we had this great old um
record player with you know we'd kind of
sit around and like just be nostalgic
about all the albums we remembered
i have i have another uh i don't know if
this is considered set dressing and i
also don't know if you have the answer
to this but it's something we see out
the window of sarah's house in
particular most often whose golf cart is
that
i don't know i haven't voiced it but oh
this is only on like second and third
watch when i'm picking up her details
but that there is a golf cart that's
just sitting outside of her window does
anyone ever use it i don't know how
weird i hope for those like starbuck cup
game of thrones
exactly i was wondering i feel like that
wasn't going to be and it looks it looks
like it has like
like tools on it yeah i feel like
someone is using it with purpose on
crockett
yes yes maybe it was matt baidel's like
his character yeah would 100 believe
that right all right let's talk a little
bit about her relationship with john
growing up or maybe lack thereof
what do you think she was thinking of
him
i mean obviously when she did not know
that he was her father and also what was
her relationship with the church growing
up too
well i think um we find a lot of
information about sarah in her
determination to stick with science
right science explains all and she needs
to find a reason to explain things
through science or medicine
and
and therefore i think that she probably
is an atheist i think that she uh
she did not feel welcome in the church
felt like an outsider
um but again not with a kind of
evil mindedness you know i think and her
relationship with john i think someone
asked me recently if i thought that
maybe she kind of always knew he was
her father and i said no no i don't
think she ever knew i think that was a
deeply buried secret
and um
and they did everything to hide it
but which makes it all the more tragic
when he comes back and you realize it's
this
desperately sad love story
and they could have anything she thought
was
judgment or hatred coming from him as a
priest
was really unrequited love for his
daughter it's quite
profound
i feel like i'm jumping all around here
but you you just
brought up that she's driven by the
science and she she's very fact driven
as well but there's one particular line
where she deviates from that that
i absolutely love and was just wondering
what it was like nailing that line it's
when she's having that conversation with
aaron about the kids getting to the
canoe and she has like a moment to think
about it when they're wondering if they
got there and then she just decided that
they did there's no evidence to prove
that they did but she decides right
there and then despite facts that they
did so what drove what was the
motivation behind that particular line i
think that was
her
exactly sort of her as as tangential as
she can get to a spiritual
uh place that was it she had to have
hope
you know she had to have hope for
humanity
uh outside the the events that were
happening you know scientifically in
front of her that everything burning
down she had to believe otherwise
her sense of purpose would have been
compromised so you know it is one of the
things that mike does so brilliantly is
he weaves in these
this is not a nihilistic
show it's it really is about
deep love and deep faith and deep hope
for for goodness you know
i love those qualities about it
um all right let's go to another line
here
[ __ ] bonkers so i'm watching i'm
watching that conversation play out and
it feels like that conversation could
have ended a beat sooner but then we get
that line and i'm super glad that it
didn't end soon or so was that always
scripted or is that something that just
happened on the spot oh no it was
scripted it was scripted and i
took great pleasure in saying it
especially after
you know mike they throw these things at
me like uh
ignaz semelweis who is you know the
researcher who offered handwashing and
then
uh erythropoietic protopulferia which i
had to say and which isn't on camera now
my it's like i can't which i can't
believe i'm so pissed
but but that's a real thing
erythropoietic protopulferia
so it was a pleasure to say [ __ ]
bonkers
um speaking of those bigger speeches
well what is what is the key to stepping
into a moment where it's so dialogue
heavy for you it's like you know for
someone out there who's about to do
their very first monologue on set what
piece of advice would you give them for
nailing things like that
[Music]
well it's always such a pleasure to work
with a filmmaker who
luxuriates in his characters being
allowed to speak
uh because sometimes it's just so pithy
otherwise so so it's
for me
i always approach a monologue of such
stature with
a tremendous excitement a little bit of
trepidation
uh because you want to nail it
and so then for me that just means
preparation like study study study you
know i mean i had my sons help me like
they all know those monologues and my
heart still
because i had to
just say them
and again they're a little bit different
because it was sort of scientific
exposition it's not just
saying how you feel
um writing that emotional current but
but uh it took a lot of preparation and
then
the grace of working with kate and alex
who
listened you know who really you could
feel
when your fellow actors are investing in
what you are saying and hearing rather
than just like
okay you're lying airline you're lying
my line
i love hearing about the value of a good
scene partner in that respect because i
don't think it's talked about nearly
enough oh listening listening
is an amazing
uh asset
i also never fully realized how unique
everyone's tactics are for learning
their lines so is there is there
anything you know
kind of out there that you do in order
to memorize all of that stuff um i have
lots of little things i first of all i'm
definitely a tactile person i need to
have my pages i can't be i don't
memorize well from screen
i have to highlight
sometimes i'll rewrite them in my own
language
uh and
sometimes i will
record the whole scene including other
people's dialogue
um
so then i can just like if i'm going for
a run i can just
get the rhythm of the words in the scene
in my psyche somehow all sorts of little
tricks having recorded some other
characters dialogue
is there any dialogue that wasn't your
own that really spoke to you that would
make you think if i could swap roles
with anybody in the midnight mass
ensemble i would pick on that
well listen uh you know
i it's such a pleasure because everybody
kind of gets their their
their piece in this whether it's robert
longstreet or
anara playing lisa she has this
beautiful monologue
um
you know kate siegel's monologue at the
end of the show i think is
one of those she and zach both have
these
beautiful sort of
they're
to me because they're science they're
almost more spiritual than just
religious
very um eternal language and i it's what
i believe ultimately and hope for you
know so
killer killer monologues
i have to ask about working with hamish
because it doesn't matter how many
things i see him in he just like blows
me away every time and i can't imagine
what it must have been like being on set
and listening to him in particular
delivered speeches like that so what is
it like just sitting you know just
sitting in the church observing him
command a room to such an extent
he is a
magnificent talent uh you know his
stature alone he's tall and dark and
handsome and
his
vocal tone itself is just
so resonant it gives you chills just to
listen to him
uh you know it's a marvel you we all
kind of again
to that point we all had to listen
to him and
hold him hold space for him to do these
massive massive
chunks of
dialogue
um
but it was it was just
lovely to watch you know and he's also a
hoot off off
you know he's not uh like so serious
like he he's
he can be pretty goofy i have gotten a
taste of that now and after seeing two
things now where he is just so
incredibly intense back to back this
year it was nice to actually get to chat
with him about this and see a little bit
of that side as well he has a lot of of
light lightness and levity this is
visual
all right
from lightness to levity to the the
massacre in the show now
what was the buildup to filming that
particular sequence like on set for all
of you what was the whole company just
like buzzing with anticipation were
nerves sky high what was it like leading
up to that
yes yes to both of those uh questions i
think we were it was at the end of our
shoot so we were we had all
grown
comfortable now with the protocols and
everything and yet we knew that they
were saving this big church sequence
with
however many extras and all of us in one
room with lots of fluids and
all of the things that the government
was not saying not advising to do during
a pandemic
and i think we'd all worked
in different pieces so much that we were
really excited to come together in the
church
you know um and in the green room offset
because we were we just had so much fun
uh but yes again it was mayhem it was
very
orchestrated choreographed
controlled mayhem but it was mayhem and
lots of moving parts and you had to pay
attention and you didn't want to get
hurt and there was
you know but it was violent and and it
was crazy because you're
looking at this set and there's
blood everywhere
you know
so to break that down a little bit here
let's go let's go to full question on
this one first of everything that
happens in that particular sequence what
what was the beat that was the toughest
to nail or to get right whether it was
because of blocking or some of that
blood anything at all well for me it was
getting shot
yes because um
you know i'm you're squibbed and it's a
stunt and a special effect or whatnot
um
and i i i don't know i it's just hard
thing to fake you know
so um
so that for me was hard but uh and then
just the emotional moment of realizing
you know that he's my father
and rejecting his offering of blood
which i think is also such a profound
statement
i mean sarah does not change her
conviction
at all
i don't know i don't know that i would
have done that i i
as annabeth i might have chosen to drink
everlasting life
i mean it's a it's a fascinating beat
because literally everything she does in
the show leads up to her making that
decision but you know you've you've
gotta you've got to account for you know
human fallibility as well and someone
might say they're not going to drink the
blood but in a moment where they're on
the brink of death
i feel like many would cave
yeah and on the brink of death men are
also on the brink of realizing this
mother and father figure that you never
knew or had as such you know that's
that's quite uh intoxicating i would
think i have another question about that
but first the second part of my my
master question is there any particular
element of like i guess the movie magic
of it all that had you standing there in
the middle of shooting a particular
scene and just saying to yourself i
can't believe that this is what it takes
to make it look like that on screen
oh gosh well there was one moment i
think that happens all the time you just
there is just a complete like you see
how many people behind the scenes it
takes some light candles
real glasses and it's so it's such a
like machine
um
but there's a shot in particular when
the
dark angel creature
arrives into the church before the
massacre actually you know
and they they have this massive crane
shot and it's just like this
you feel the kinetic energy of the
cinematography
and that's like one of those moments
where you're like oh we're making some
cool [ __ ]
what did you guys casually call it on
set because in talking about the show
with friends like some say angels some
say demons some do a combination i don't
even know anymore
is it an angel is it a demon is it a
vampire i it's all all of those things
it's it's a creature of mike flanagan's
imagination
it was it a conscious choice to
like i guess this is more of a my
question but to never utter the word
vampire in the show
i would guess that that was a very
conscious decision knowing mike
everything is very very spotted
here's here's another uh very specific
question about that there there is there
is one point where sarah connects
uh eep
to
maybe fueling a certain myth is she
referring to
like the myths that we have created
about vampires okay yeah yes yes you get
the one and only reference to vampires
oh i know and i love that you are only
saying eep instead of
erythropoietic
not not even gonna try not even gonna
try
all right my last question for you is a
big one i was wondering what you think
that sarah's last words might have been
if she had had the chance to utter
something because in that moment there's
something about you know the the pacing
in the way that it shot that was making
me think maybe she's gonna turn to john
and she's gonna say something like no
but but she doesn't and then i just got
obsessed with what she might have said
given that in the scene before
she agrees with him and says that she
would have liked to have known him
better but then refuses the blood yes
which which again
i have such admiration for her because i
think even so
at the end of our life we probably all
just really want love so i even though
she says no to
the everlasting life
i think she would have said
i i love you you know to her mom and her
dad you know
or
something like that you know that's my
sentimental side
that's that's how i read it i'm glad now
it just you know it further uh
uh
validates it because you said it and it
also fills my heart which with a show
that ends the way it does it's it's
incredible that it manages to be
heartening in the end and inspiring
isn't it though it gives me chills
because you and it really is that kind
of you know i know everyone is urging
people to watch the entirety of the show
which you must because the ride itself
is it's the journey you know it's not
just the destination and and but once
you end at the end then it's like
wow holy [ __ ]
does not does not surprise me with with
a cast like yours and someone like mike
at the helm i've seen him do it time and
time again i should never be surprised
but this this was an ambitious show and
i'm very very impressed by how well you
all pull it off well good thank you yeah
i'm honored to be a part of it i must
thank you for spending some time with us
and thank you for asking my answering my
uh my super detailed spoiler questions
here i appreciate it i love it i love it
let him rip yeah huge congratulations
and thanks again for chatting with us
thank you